bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo spécial
élections européennes dans cette
émission je vous emmène en pologne à la
lisière de l'enclavé russe de
kaliningrad les échanges entre polonais
et russes là-bas à son quotidien
pourtant depuis quelques mois et le
début de la crise en ukraine les
polonais s'inquiètent
et si la pologne était la prochaine
cible de vladimir poutine
mais d'abord l'actualité en galas et
françois sont dans un bateau
manuel valls en opération séduction et
viktor orban
réélu dans un fauteuil alors une
campagne à bout de souffle
c'est la question de la semaine
on
au creux d'une semaine de campagne
petite croisière romantique sur la
baltique pour françois hollande et en
gala merkel une visite informelle une
atmosphère chaleureuse et détendue
une carte postale qui dénote avec le
sérieux des sujets abordés crise russo
ukrainienne dépendance énergétique
élections européennes choix du futur
président de la commission
une rencontre au sommet pour tenter de
dissiper les accrocs dans le couple
franco allemand notamment sur les
pointes question du déficit français
quant à la pluie battante qui arrosait
ces retrouvailles françois hollande a
tenu à rassurer depuis deux ans il y est
habitué et cela ne lui pose aucun
problème
pendant ce temps à paris sur le plateau
de tf1 c'est le premier ministre en
personne qui tente une danse du ventre
pour convaincre les électeurs de
s'intéresser un minimum aux européennes
un scrutin décisif majeur pour l'avenir
de la france et de l'europe
la dramatisation levier principal pour
motiver les électeurs
un peu court non l'argument du choix du
futur président de la commission ne fait
pas recette
et même le front national redoutent une
abstention comprise historique
pourtant il y à un flat sion sur les
listes pas moins de trente et une réac
en ile de france
à ce rythme les français auront plus les
candidats que de bonnes torres
à l'autre bout de l'europe c'est victor
ban qui savoure sa victoire
les dernières élections législatives en
hongrie ont confirmé son assise sur le
parlement la coalition du toujours
premier ministre souffle 133 299 sièges
un triomphe
et cérémonie d'investiture en forme de
fanfaronnade dans une union européenne
qui n'en finit pas de pointer sa dérive
autocratique
alors sans soufre cette campagne est
avec moi en plateau pour discuter de
cette campagne qui démarre ou pas j'ai
plusieurs invités dominique aquatique
bonjour bonjour vous êtes journaliste
polonaise pour le journal dziennik
gazeta prawna venarsal j'ai bien dit bon
ça va
cédric pellen bonjour vous êtes
politologue à l'ulb l'université libre
de bruxelles vous êtes spécialiste des
questions européennes et notamment du
bloc de l'est et notamment de la pologne
dont on parlera un peu plus tard
christophe garage bonjour vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du site europolitique
alors je vais tout de suite vous
m'adressez avoue dominique et en
particulier est ce que vous diriez que
la campagne est à bout de souffle ou
est-ce que la campagne n'a pas démarré
en europe comment ça se passe en pologne
en grèce était nous avons toujours parlé
de situation on craint aussi c'est pas
seulement question de campagne pour
élections européennes mais aussi j'ai
très très important et pour tout la
partie pour l'enneigement reste donc en
fait oui mais ça on va en parler
justement de la crise ukrainienne dans
une seconde partie de l'émission
cédric perrin est ce que vous considérez
que la campagne a démarré ou est ce que
vraiment c'est partout pareil en europe
tout le monde s'en fiche finalement en
pologne il faut pas oublier le contexte
politique particulier on est à un an
d'élections présidentielles et
parlementaires à quelques mois
d'élections locales
les élections européennes sont prises au
sérieux par relativement peu de partis
c'est perçu comme des élections
d'entraînement on parle très peu de
l'europe en pologne actuellement on
parle beaucoup effectivement de
l'ukraine on parle beaucoup de questions
énergétiques et surtout on a une
répétition générale de l'opposition
entre plateforme civique le parti du
premier ministre est droit et justice le
parti de jaroslaw catching et dans le
reste de l'europe parce que c'est la
même chose partout vous dirais que le
cas polonais ou le cas français de cette
campagne qui a du mal à démarrer quai à
thoune
c'est un peu près partout comme ça
j'aurais du mal à l'exprimer sur
l'ensemble des 28 pays et effectivement
il me semble que dans la plupart des
pays on a cette dynamique de campagne
nationalisée on parle de l'europe du
bout des lèvres dans des mesures
différentes selon les pays en pologne on
en parle relativement peu christophe
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous vous
êtes belle si je puis dire résidente
depuis quelques temps est ce que c'est
le même problème partout est ce que vous
vous êtes analyser la même chose la
volonté du parlement européen s'était
notamment de présidentialiser cette
élection avec des candidats pour la
présidence de la commission européenne
alors le débat a commencé extrêmement
tardivement il ya des alévis en quinze
jours c'est compliqué de d'inverser une
tendance profonde où effectivement les
choses et les citoyens ont du mal à
comprendre les enjeux en tout cas ils
voient bien eu ski le ski leur compte
c'est l'emploi aujourd'hui et pas sûr
que prétendent aujourd'hui aussi des
critères qui revient systématiquement
qui reprises d'ailleurs par la plupart
des partis dans leur programme et il
n'est pas sûr que la campagne
aujourd'hui répondent vraiment aux
inquiétudes de ses citoyens c'est 26
millions de personnes qui vont
travailler aujourd'hui cédric là quand
on voit le cac viktor orban qui a été
pointée du doigt par l'union européenne
pendant des années du moins par les
députés ici est ce que finalement
c'est pas une fanfaronnade la de le voir
triompher se dire que on a un petit peu
cette problématique à dire voilà vous
vous êtes un autocrate mais finalement
le peuple veut quand même oui c'est sûr
c'est une contradiction apparente
les dirigeants nationaux sont élus au
niveau national et viktor orban s'est
aussi servie l'union européenne pour
renforcer sa popularité au niveau
national pour s'affirmer justement comme
un homme de conviction qui n'a pas peur
d'aller s'opposer avec bruxelles et
c'est des méthodes qui sont mises en
oeuvre dans d'autres pays on voit bien
ce jeu ambivalent entre ce qu'on dit à
bruxelles est ce qu'on dit au niveau
national et viktor orban effectivement
est sortie renforcée on peut dire du
bras de fer qui la rend qu'il amenait
avec avec bruxelles
et aujourd'hui il faut faire avec or
balle mais c'est une évidence il n'y a
pas vraiment d'opposition forte
structure et en gris urban et là sur la
durée dominique a
quand vous voyez angela merkel et
françois hollande qui sont en croisière
comme ça pour se demander tient est ce
que on va se est-ce qu'on va se laisser
dicter entre guillemets notre choix pour
le président de la commission est ce que
vous pourriez dire vous de votre côté
est-ce qu'on pologne c'est du moins ce
qu'on pense est ce que c'est encore le
couple franco-allemand qui dirige entre
guillemets qui est leader en europe en
parle nous avons toujours tandem couple
franco-allemand est elle ne savons pas
changer l'opinion
et oui je pense que ça s'était toujours
et quelqu'un coalition entre berlin et
paris est dedans pendant cette élection
c'est ainsi visibles cédric plein
comment est ce qu'on explique ça en fait
que ce soit toujours ce moteur qui
pensent qu'ils fonctionnent si je puis
dire qu'il fonctionne mal je ne sais pas
justement si c'est un moteur qui
fonctionne toujours de manière aussi
nette effectivement on attend toujours
une impulsion franco allemands mais il
me semble notamment la pologne et
d'autres pays cherche également à
s'affirmer à faire entendre leur voix et
à transformer ce duo un ensemble plus
élargie de grands pays moteur et la
pologne depuis son adhésion en 2004
cherche à jouer ce rôle 1,2 d'un des
grands pays la population comme la
comparable à celle de l'espagne une
économie en plus tôt meilleure santé que
les échos 3 4% de croissance
il avait une économie géré baisse mais
n'y a pas eu de récession déjà en
pologne
nous voulons être quant au leader
régional leader est nouveau donc
effectivement c'est la volonté de la
pologne de faire entendre sa voir sans
forcément remettre en cause la
prédominance des grands états tels que
la france et l'allemagne mais se faire
entendre ça c'est une volonté quand même
le gouvernement tous que depuis un an
christophe quand on voit ce couple
franco allemand en croisière est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un quand même un
déséquilibre alors qu on sait bien quel
est le poids aujourd'hui de la france
dans la structure
alors pour être positif on peut
constater que les allemands comme les
français sont désormais débarrassé d'un
calendrier électoral national ils ont
une petite fenêtre de tir devant eux
disons après les élections européennes
et angela merkel à la tête de sa grosse
coalition' depuis déjà quelques temps le
il n'y aura pas d'élection en france
avant aux deux ans il y aura des
élections intermédiaires mais disons que
l'agenda des deux chefs d'état est
peut-être plus disponibles les deux sont
peut-être plus disponible aujourd'hui
pour faire des propositions il faudra
sans doute attendre évidemment les
résultats de l'élection
alors quel type de proposition on peut
attendre alors à y aller de yale
problème de le choix du président de la
commission
alors ça c'est rare est qu'ils vont
accepter ou pas de se laisser dicter
leurs choix par les urnes entre
guillemets ce que vous y croyez
à ce stade il y encore on n'est qu'à
quelques jours des élections et c'est
vrai qu'il y à beaucoup d'incertitudes
d'autant que c'est le parlement à la fin
le parlement européen qui vote et qui
décident oui ou non et qui confirme la
candidature d'un président la commission
européenne donc difficile d'imaginer une
guerre interinstitutionnelle il ya eu
des alertes
les deux principaux candidats martine
chose pour les sociaux-démocrates et
jean claude juncker pour le ppe ont déjà
annoncées et mises en garde les chefs
d'état contre une dérive démocratique
si le conseil européen décide est de
leur faire qu'à sa tête
donc là dessus le couple franco-allemand
peut-être plus du côté alban d'ailleurs
que du côté français
va devoir faire avec cette nouvelle
donne politique
alors je voudrais qu'on revienne
justement sur le cac polonaise figurez
vous que depuis le début de la crise
ukrainienne donc en décembre dernier et
une secousse qui si je puis dire qui a
été beaucoup plus lourde de conséquences
en février dernier
eh ben les polonais sont assez inquiets
de voir cette crise aux portes de
l'europe notamment ceux qui sont à la
frontière de l'enclavé russe en europe
de kaliningrad
on a voulu se rendre là bas pour un
petit peu se rendre compte de la
situation c'est un reportage de sandra
cerqueira et on en parle juste après
lena bien faire le plein chaque semaine
elle est russe mais fait ses courses ici
en pologne
je traverse la frontière parce que les
prix sont plus bas
les produits polonais sont deux à trois
fois moins cher que les produits d
n'habite à 10 km dans l'enclavé russe de
kaliningrad
comme elle ils sont des milliers chaque
mois à venir à bartovic et ville
polonaise de 20000 habitants qui compte
pas moins de dix grandes surfaces les
russes se sont ceux qui ont les caddies
les plus remplies jean et je roule à
l'économie locale repose sur ce commerce
transfrontalier
mais depuis la crise en ukraine les
relations entre russes et polonais se
compliquer une situation qui préoccupe
le maire non depuis janvier les russes
nous imposent un embargo sur la viande
de porc européenne et maintenant qu'ils
ont décidé de nous imposer un embargo
sur les produits agricoles polonais
comme les fruits et les légumes
c'est une paire de retombées économiques
pour nous on essaye tout de même de
continuer à investir et à développer la
ville comme si de rien n'était
cette coiffeuse aussi suit avec angoisse
les tensions en ukraine je connais
beaucoup de russes qui ne veulent pas de
la guerre ce qui l'inquiète c'est la
sécurité de son pays pour la première
fois depuis la chute du bloc communiste
elles pensent que la menace militaire à
l'est est bien réelle il ya une méfiance
qui s'installent ici nous sommes très
proches de la frontière et on ne peut
pas prévoir ce qui se passe dans la tête
de poutine
c'est devenu un voisin imprévisible à
tout moment a envoyé des troupes pour
atteindre ses objectifs
je ne regarde plus la télévision ça me
fait peur ce qui se passe à la frontière
entre la pologne et la russie
la tente peut être longue il faut à
chaque fois ouvrir son coffre et montrer
ses papiers
car ici s'arrête l'espace schengen nous
n'avons aucun contact avec les russes on
ne se parle pas il n'y a que des
relations commerciales entre nous nous
allons chercher de l'essence moins cher
chez eux et eux ils viennent faire leurs
courses
c'est tout ça s'arrête là les polonais
n'oublie pas que de l'autre côté
l'enclavé de kaliningrad et surarmés une
présence militaire russe qui pourrait
s'avérer menaçante
certains polonais avoue être soulagés
d'appartenir à l'otan et à l'union
européenne
la crise ukrainienne au coeur des
européennes et avec elle la question de
la sécurité de la pologne
devenu un thème de campagne avec des
candidats pro européen en tête dans les
sondages
ici à la centrale à charbon de varsovie
l'europe on en parle beaucoup
oui oui mais la centrale a été
modernisée et nous émettons moins de co2
les subventions de bruxelles ont financé
en partie les filtres qui permettent de
moins polluer
moi je veux bien sûr parler des défauts
du charbon mais il possède des avantages
bien plus importants pour le charbon
permet de combler quasiment tous nos
besoins en chauffage et en électricité
près de 90 % de notre électricité
provient du charbon et pour répondre à
l'augmentation de la demande
la pologne a aussi décidé de se tourner
vers le nucléaire elle ne compte pas
abandonner le gaz de schiste et envisage
même de développer les énergies
renouvelables
le but est de diversifier les sources
d'énergie pour assurer la stabilité de
notre production et assurer notre
sécurité et notre indépendance
énergétique à mars
autrement dit faire en sorte de réduire
les importations de gaz russe la pologne
réclament aujourd'hui une europe de
l'énergie pour que l'union européenne ne
dépende plus au temps des ressources de
la russie
dominika je me tourne vers vous on
entendait cette coiffeuse dans le
village de bartovic et qu'ils disaient
poutine est un voisin imprévisible est
ce que vous êtes d'accord
faisant très difficile ça c'est pas de
première fois quand merci poutine à
faire quelque chose c'est très très
inquiétante à l'un des mineurs
nous tous savons très 2008 on était dès
lors la georgie c'était la première fois
qu'on merci poutine a présenté son
visage et son vrai visage et il est très
difficile voisin pour la pologne
il ya aussi positif le résultat de cet
eagle en higuain dernière que nous avons
accompli que nous avons besoin très fort
la politique de défense et téléphonie
polonais deuxième est que nous avons
communiqué regrette vraiment coupé comme
unité énergétique
oui effectivement la question de
l'énergie se pose évidemment avoir dit
non non non pas sur ses réactions
est ce que vous êtes d'accord cédric
pollen est ce qu'il ya un risque en fait
de pour la pologne de se voir enfin de
se voir subir le même sort que l'ukraine
alors non je pense pas je pense que la
pologne soit dans la même situation que
l'ukraine la pologne est membre de
l'union européenne la pologne est membre
de l'otan une stabilité politique qui
n'est pas celle qu'ils avaient l'ukraine
avant la crise
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il ya des
relations diplomatiques avec la russie
qui sont complexes de longue durée que
la pologne était un des pays qui portait
le plus l'idée d'une politique de
voisinage et notamment à l'égard de
l'ukraine donc là ce qui se passe
actuellement en ukraine ballon contré
s'était beaucoup investie d'ailleurs
dans la négociation avec cette idée de
sécuriser sa frontière orientale à
présent effectivement donald tous se
mobilisent cette question ukrainienne
très très fortement dans la campagne
aussi pour s'affirmer pour réaffirmer
son autorité de chef d'état la campagne
européenne je les dis et re-nationaliser
des chefs de partis qui s'investissent
dans la campagne alors même qu'ils ne
sont pas candidats aux élections
européennes c'est la préparatifs des
élections nationales mais prochaine et
donald tusk s'est positionné comme chef
de guerre un petit peu garantes de la
sécurité
plaide pour une europe forte en terme de
sécurité et s'est aussi fait le porte
parole effectivement d'une politique
européenne énergétique afin de réduire
la dépendance de l'union européenne en
général à l'égard du gaz russe c'est
justement un petit peu le noeud du
problème cette dépendance énergétique et
à la russie là on voit que les russes
donnent un ultimatum à l'ukraine et ils
couperont le gaz au 3 juin s'ils n'ont
pas payé d'avancés les 3 milliards soit
disant que gazprom réclame à l'ukraine
d'arriérés ou est-ce qu'on en mette
cette europe de l'énergie la vérité
c'est que aujourd'hui les états membres
lorsqu'il s'agit de sécuriser
c'est leur propre approvisionnement
énergétique ne pense pas europe d'abord
pense d'abord nationales à l'allemagne
la france quand il s'agit de constituer
des stocks et de prévoir d'avoir la
prévisibilité sur les stocks de gaz va
négocier les états vont négocier
directement avec poutine avec gazprom
pour sécuriser leurs approvisionnements
toute la question est de l'europe et
anisé cette façon de voir les choses
alors qu'à un moment de lâcher du lest
un de lâcher une compétence nationale
pour la donner à l'europe pour que on
négocie à 28 plutôt qu'à 1
et là c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
beaucoup plus compliquées alors là
dessus il ya un instrument qui s'appelle
la communauté européenne de l'énergie
qui est une instance dont personne ne
parle et qui existe depuis quelques
temps pour lequel pour laquelle
l'ukraine l'ukraine dont l'ukraine est
membre et pour laquelle donc la
communauté invitent la russie a intégré
cette communauté toute la question est
de savoir si cette 7e cette structure
serait capable de négocier et d'apaiser
les relations a à court et moyen termes
là encore c'est un grand défi puisque la
souveraineté des états en matière
d'énergie est primordial encore
aujourd'hui de mini cars
on dit dans le reportage les partis pro
européens sont globalement en tête des
sondages je vous laisse me le confirmer
mais est ce qu'on considère en pologne
que l'europe et est encore une porte de
sortie par une porte de sortie c'est un
peu difficile comme terme mais est ce
que c'est encore une solution pour la
paix est ce que c'est une protection et
je ne suis pas psy est ce qu'elle est ce
que l'on nous ne croyons que c'est
l'autre qui est notre garantie et ça
c'est je pense que maintenant c'est
parce que ces américains qui n a pas mal
et flottant oui ça c'est l'otan et
américaines d'abord en deuxième place
cédric on a on a encore un fort
sentiment européen dans les pays qui ont
été intégrés il ya peu de temps dans les
pays de l'est
oui mais comme une évidence pas quelque
chose qui soit l'objet de débats
politiques les participations aux
élections européennes qui sont
excessivement bassin dans les pays
d'europe centrale orientale en 2004 et
en 2009 en pologne
elles ne dépasseront certainement pas
les 20 à 25% grand maximum c'est le même
problème partout au final beaucoup plus
poussée encore à la pologne et parmi les
records d'abstention aux élections
européennes c'est pour ça que c'est
l'élection qui investit comme une action
d'entraînement l'idée de chaque parti
c'est de pas trop perdre d'effectifs par
le marocain mais ce n'est pas perçue
comme une extrême importance après
politiquement effectivement il ya
beaucoup de 17,6 faction à l'égard d'une
europe qui est perçue avant tout comme
un grand marché et donner tout ce que la
pointe et avec cette question de la
politique énergétique qui effectivement
absentes pour le voyez christophe on
on a quand même là quelque chose d'assez
évident sur les 28 c'est que globalement
l'europe on y est c'est une évidence
mais les taux d'abstention s'annonce
historique partout est-ce qu'il ya par
un problème d'incarnation au delà juste
du président du conseil européen
est ce qu'il ya des solutions
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des pays ou
chez les représentants politiques sur
comment incarner l'europe et comment il
comment faire croire aux citoyens à
l'europe alors les parlementaires
européens ont déjà leurs discours tout
près au lendemain des élections
lorsqu'il s'agira de constater je
désactive en dire et qu'est ce qu'ils
vont dire ils vont prendre une fois de
plus comme ils l'ont fait en 2009
comparaison avec les états unis et les
élections les mid term elections
oui au congrès américain et son ancien
pape qui ne passionne pas les foules
autour de 50% de partisans allons voir -
parfois et de me démontrer et de de
questionner l'opinion publique en disant
est ce que pour autant les etats-unis ne
sont pas une grande démocratie
internationale malgré mais même s'ils
ont mal élu après tout c'est pas grave
donc le discours est déjà rodé et
certains candidats dont jean claude
juncker ont déjà rappelé cet événement
candidate vivant avant les élections et
bien justement une des personnes qui
incarnent cette union européenne
d'aujourd'hui herman van rompuy s'est
exprimé sur la question des sanctions à
la russie je voudrais qu'on écoute
l'union européenne est d'avis que de
nouvelles mesures de la part de la
russie visant à déstabiliser la
situation en ukraine mènerait à des
conséquences supplémentaires sur un
nombre important de questions
économiques
le travail préparatoire est déjà en
cours nous sommes prêts à prendre des
décisions supplémentaires si nécessaire
de when we are ready to take foundation
eff nez ou là alors nous sommes prêts à
prendre des décisions supplémentaires
est ce que c'est une menace c'est ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à des sanctions
incroyable de la part de l'union
européenne vis-à-vis de la russie
dominique à vous y croyez et dans la
section non non non je pense que c'est
possible parce que quand nous regardons
pour les différents pays qui ont fait
100 sitif très bonnes relations
économiques avec l'art aussi je ne crois
pas que les actions sont possibles
c'est pas bon non je suis réaliste
cédric comment se fait-il que cette
politique de sanctions soient aussi
frileuse timide en europe quand on voit
ce que les états unis ont été capables
de faire vis-à-vis de la russie
votre reportage sur la pologne le
montrait bien il ya des interdépendances
économiques très forte qu'on le veuille
ou non avec avec la russie la pologne en
a au niveau agricole donc des sanctions
sont aussi potentiellement coûteuse à
l'est du port la question énergétique
on est en plein dedans l'allemagne
grosse dépendance à l'égard du gaz russe
des prix très avantageux pour le moment
donc les sanctions elles sont peut-être
plus coûteuses pour les pays de l'union
européenne que pour les états unis du
fait de ces échanges commerciaux
typiquement là on a vu que là les
sanctions mises en place par les états
unis étaient assez volontaire il ya
quand même des très proches de poutine
qui on est et qui ont été ciblés c'est
quoi c'est le fait qu'il n'ait plus de
dépendance énergétique le pétrole de
schiste a fait deux presque d
indépendant énergétiquement qu'ils font
que leur la réelle politique est
aujourd'hui différent de ce qu'elle n'a
pu l'être pendant quelques années
l'effet commerciaux sont là le
les etats unis sont moins dépendants de
leurs relations commerciales avec la
russie que peut-être l'europe c'est une
chose la deuxième chose que je voulais
dire c'est quoi le les européens
devraient faire la guerre à la russie
pour défendre l'ukraine
il n'y a absolument aucune volonté
d'engagement des vies terre c'est
évident et on pense aussi vous savez
c'est un peu comme le billard on pense
déjà au coup d'après on a les européens
ont besoin de la russie dans beaucoup
d'autres dossiers le dossier énergétique
d'une part mais dans les relations avec
l'iran dans les relations avec la syrie
dans les relations avec la chine
il ne sait pas se froisser non plus on
ne peut pas froisser le grand voisin
voilà c'est la realpolitik et penser
déjà au coude après donc ils sont bien
embêtés néanmoins rappelé quasiment
semaine après semaine que le risque de
passer à la phase iii pour des sanctions
beaucoup plus dures à l'égard de la
russie
est-ce que ça inquiète poutine j'ai
ensuite pas du tout combien on n'a pas
l'impression on a quand même le
sentiment que l'europe privilégie la
diplomatie si je puis dire feutrée sauf
que on a une haute représentante
catherine ashton qui a eu du mal en fait
à s'imprégner c'est ce que dire de son
mandat fin du mois qui a été très
critiqué durant son mandat
on est censé en europe à avoir des
réseaux diplomatiques le plus important
du monde cédric collet est ce que
finalement on n'est pas là dans une
forme de mythe de la diplomatie
européenne sachant que sur le cac
l'ukrainien il ya eu énormément
d'attentisme et on en est à une
situation de blocage aujourd'hui qu'en
est il de cette diplomate ça dépend des
situations effectivement sur certains
sujets sensibles parce qu'il renvoie à
des intérêts nationaux différents sont
les états membres on voit bien qu'il ya
beaucoup de difficultés à faire à une
position commune et je crois que c'est
exactement le cas actuellement avec
l'ukraine on a certains pays qui sont
très investis dans le dossier très
intéressé qui veulent effectivement des
positions extrêmement ferme
c'est le cas de la pologne d'autres pays
qui fondamentalement ne se sentent pas
concernés ou alors ont des intérêts
différents
on voit les milliardaires russes à
londres pèse certainement dans certaines
décisions britannique la dépendance à
l'égard du gaz russe va peser aussi dans
d'autres pays et donc dans ces
situations là quand il ya des intérêts
visuellement divergent notamment au
niveau économique
on a effectivement beaucoup de
difficultés à avoir une position commune
je crois que c'est ce à quoi on assiste
actuellement christophe sur ce débat
autour de la diplomatie européenne ça
aussi c'est une grande chimères après
l'europe de l'énergie
on peut pas être ensemble à 28 en tout
cas en tout cas sur le papier il ya plus
d'avancé sur leurs en termes de volonté
d'unifier de parler d'une voix d'une
seule voix au niveau de la diplomatie
européenne aux affaires étrangères que
sur la question de l'énergie
il ya un vrai il ya encore un vrai gap
entre les possibilités les plus avancés
sur la sur la lazio et de ce que l'on
peut faire et de ce que l'on veut faire
des outils législatifs des outils
constitutionnels qui sont gravées dans
les traités européens pour la question
des affaires étrangères et j'ai
l'impression que pour l'instant encore
les grandes capitales ne prennent pas
très au sérieux le rôle de madame ashton
bon bah écoutez en attendant il y a
quelque chose qui arrive à contenter
tout le monde c'est l'eurovision merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat nous on se
quitte avec ces quelques images de
conchita furent ce qui est la grande
gagnante qu'ils rentraient chez eux
en autriche triomphalement donc je vous
laisse écouter cette magie de savoie
merci à vous d'avoir participé à cette
émission est de 1 se retrouve la semaine
prochaine